since we do or you know we didn't
mention voice we do lots of voice like
calling we do lots of ideas for
companies with all of the synthetic
voice with all of the solutions that you
have on the ai
if you want to be sensitive to your
clients if you want to give them the
personal approach the technology is
still behind we are also ourselves
investing a lot in technology in ai in
different automation stores but we know
that if we won't have the human factor
to make the risk of refining the the
processes we
we
won't give the right experience to the
clients and and we know that it's also
affecting the conversion when it comes
to evidence
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
hello and welcome to another episode
let's talk about localization with the
ear tal the ceo of blend localization
services he is a seasoned executive with
extensive b2b and enterprise experience
passionate about developing long-term
solutions for strategic partners and
customers his interests lie in
connecting local talent with global
companies and removing cross-border
barriers to empower growth he joined
bland formerly our one hour translation
as a ceo in 2020 with a strong passion
to transform the localization industry
and remove cross-border barriers for
growth stage companies and brands before
joining bland he served as senior vice
president head of payoneer enterprise at
payoneer a leading cross-border payments
platform
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm okay thanks for having me nice being
here
thank you
thank you very very much for being here
ceo of blend a previously senior vice
president with enterprise at payoneer
which i mentioned i love the company and
i'm about to love blend too after this
conversation and because we're going to
be talking about a problem that
virtually every company faces especially
in a globalized world today where we're
not just creating a product for a
specific demographic or a specific
language but it's really the whole world
with however many languages there are
and and we and localization and the
whole challenge there is something that
the blend helps tackle and so i'm
excited to talk about that but before
that yo tell me a little bit about
yourself about your own journey and sort
of what guides you and your perspective
uh throughout your career
um you know as you mentioned i i came
from pioneer and i've been with pioneer
for many years um leading the enterprise
side of the business and it's in a way
it's very similar to what we're doing
here it's a b2b solution
it's a solution uh that you're actually
designing for client you're designing
for clients that are trying to grow
globally the
many challenges when you when you want
to work globally that you need to remove
barriers uh when it comes to payment
when it comes to languages when it comes
to cultures and working with companies
for the long term building their
relationship understanding their needs
and then developing the solution that
they need
this is what i like the most that's why
i did the pioneer this is what i'm doing
here uh in actually i have many
many customers that i used to work with
them at pioneer working with them here
at blend so i'm enjoying it and enjoying
the journey yes
i love it okay so now talking more
specifically about globalization
localization and what's happening with
the world today before we even talk
about blend
paint me a picture of the pain of the
pain that you're solving you know what's
what's happening that makes blend a
necessity in today's world
so um you know it's uh today it's really
hard to talk about any trends without
mentioning covet
because this is the reality that we are
living in uh we we were being at
recovery at some point we thought we can
start talking about post coverage and
now we see that we it's too early to
talk about post copy and you see that a
lot of things actually changing in the
world
you see that companies that used to
manage their business locally
suddenly
there are many options for them to grow
globally you see that companies youtube
was walk offline they need to go online
and you see that uh
different regulations that used to be
before actually being removed or
actually changed the pictures and then
companies have new opportunities to grow
their business
and if i used to buy on specific stores
locally that i went down in the street
and to buy there now i can go online buy
the same straight but buying many other
stuff and so for me as a consumer i get
lots of new options that they didn't
have before but on the other hand
for the
sellers for their businesses uh that
they were limited before they're not
limited anymore it's in a way it's very
similar to what we used to have with the
taxi drivers then it moves to be the
uber that then you have endless options
right saying here but it's not only the
uber locally it's the internationally
endless options for me to sell and to
grow my business but then i get into a
challenge
but how do i deal with the culture gaps
how do i deal with the land right and in
and more and and that really encompasses
the idea of localization right that
exact challenge making things local for
culture for language for everything and
and by the way uh you know
with the blend before it was blend we
were
one hour translation and we went through
a whole process of how do we want to
really uh define the company as far as
what we do and what is the right three
branding that we wanted to do and the
reason that we chose blend
is only uh because we realized that if
you want to grow your company into a new
market you need to compete with low
locals and it's it's very challenging to
compete with locals when you don't speak
their language but mostly that you don't
speak the culture
and what you need to do is that you need
to blend into a culture you need to
blend into your country in order to win
in order to grow your business
and basically
most of the reasons why we decided to
call the company plan to rebrand the
plan
so what what is sort of a how does a
strategy look like you know from
a business's perspective before blen's
perspective i'm as a business owner what
sort of strategy
should i even be thinking through as i'm
expanding and as i'm approaching new
cultures or new demographics so it
starts on the culture so you need to
have a culture fit for your products and
to make sure that they're actually
relevant in a civilian in a different
market you know we work with the gaming
companies that there are a lot of
regulations in other countries that
there's no it's a blocker there's no
point for them even to trying to go
there
because they would be blocked by the
regulation and the same with the
e-commerce e-commerce they may have
restrictions on on specific products
that it won't be a good fit or it might
be even a culture
gap that the product that they used to
sell in one country wouldn't be a good
fit in another country and we have
endless examples of websites and and
reports that we created for companies
that they saw that the conversion in
russia was low for them and when they
realize that the product in the way the
the they publish it in russia is not in
good fit and the same in brazil and the
same in china uh so you really need to
fit
and to make sure that your product is is
a good fit for the country for the
domain that you want to explore and you
want to extend your business into so
that would be the first thing that you
have to do the research before and one
thing we do for companies we actually we
prepare the reports for them making sure
that this there is a good fit for them
to explore this mark and then once they
do it obviously you start to get into
new challenges of okay now i know
there's a fit for me how do i do it how
do i approach the markets what do i
start to communicate in first and and
how do i build my wallet shirt in the
specific content
and so
how does a process like this actually
look so what how does blend actually
come and take a company
and help it realize what could
materialize in in another culture
another demographic but then more
interestingly how do you actually go
about making this transition with them
or additionally
we love working with the companies that
are looking to explore like you know uh
there's some companies that actually
come into us and said during comet
we used to work with the resellers so we
never sold products by ourselves but now
during covet some of the stores were
closed so we decided that we want to do
it ourselves and a good example is
exactly to take one client that we had
that they decided that they want to
go into new markets they came with a
list of 25 countries that they would
like to explore
together with them we basically look
into the specific countries and realize
that it won't be a good feat to start
with all of them when we pick together
17 because we assume
based on the research that we have with
the local uh talents that we work with
in each country that
it won't be a good fit
in specific places and would be much
better fit in other places and we picked
and i'm guessing that
a part of this is also that they may be
looking at it from an angle of you know
in terms of where where their product
can better materialize you know
financially and get more traction you're
coming in there with it with an angle
though of of a better culture fit right
and whether to see this is actually you
know you understanding these cultures in
a different way with with more
experience you could actually envision
or predict how they would perceive the
product better perhaps than the company
and it's very important to do it with
local talent so we we tested many
programs we tested many
products and we realized that we worked
with a company that it's all based on
youtube movies and and all of the
material that they have actually based
on youtube but then it wouldn't work on
in china so you don't want to start in
china while you know that you need to
duplicate all of your content into a
different platform while you can start
in other countries with what you have
already and then we work with the
company that they actually doing some
body
you know beauty products that they
wouldn't be good fit in some other
countries that they
more conservative and we said let's this
is where we see the highest uh
chances for you to start with the
highest chances to uh conversion and to
start your business with and we picked
the 17
once we did it we said okay now we need
to help them to write the content
because the content that they have in
english
if you just translate the content to a
different language it wouldn't be good
enough you need to be uh you need to do
the job adoptions to the culture that
will better explain the product the
advantages and how to describe it so
you'll get more traffic so now you want
to move on to the seo and to
build article and build their websites
design their websites you know
left to right right to left and other
challenges they may have on their site
all the way
to the you know
payment page all the way to the uh
retention of the second buy and so on
now how similar is this process across
companies do you find that it's mostly
similar or do you really have to
reinvent the whole thinking strategy
with every company that comes in
so there are lots of there are a lot of
similarities when you go into the
specific specific verticals so obviously
on the e-commerce you'll see lots of
similarities uh when you talk about
physical goods there are lots of
similarities however it only depends on
the products that they have and the
countries where that is selling from so
here you'll have lots of uh changes but
if you go to gaming it will be different
if you go to legal stuff if you go to
pharma that actually since we support
many verticals uh over there you see
different challenges that that they they
are all facing but as you go in the
vertical into the vertical then there
are really lots of things that we can
duplicate and we can design for them
just do the adjustment based on their
products and based on their needs and
and so
so as we transition you know into a more
globalized world obviously solutions
like blend you know they're critical and
um and are something that you know that
are more that is just becoming more and
more necessary as we transition there do
you see
a shift in you know the way that things
are being done though to get to get
localization is there are yeah in other
words do you do you believe that you
know in the coming years we're going to
see people across the world becoming
more similar in a way that perhaps you
won't need to localize as much or is
this the need that is going to keep
growing with separate cultures
you know you can go back to the bible
when uh you know
we know about different uh cases when
people try to speak the same language
but it didn't work well right and i
think this is where we all you know it's
an ongoing endless challenge that we are
trying to get
between cultures and between the
languages and to speak the same language
um
if you know investing money in a company
that
if you think this is the risk that
everyone will speak the same language i
feel comfortable that they will take
uh many more years before we will all
speak the same language and and you can
share the same culture so because it's
not only translation so i assume that
there are more and more solutions with
with
ai solutions for for gapping the
different languages but the culture is a
huge challenge for localization you can
have an amazing product right amazing
if you move into japan trying to sell it
in japan and you don't do the
adjustments for the culture you have no
chance you have no chance to grow your
business and just write it locally and
still even when you look into uh since
we do you know we didn't mention voice
we do lots of voice like calling we do
lots of ideas for companies with all of
the synthetic voice with all of the
solutions that you have on the ai
if you want to be sensitive to your
clients if you want to give them the
personal approach the technology
is still behind we are also ourselves
investing a lot in technology in ai in
different automation stores but we know
that if we won't have the human factor
to make the risk of refining the the
processes we
we won't give the right experience to
the clients and and we know that it's
also affecting the conversion when it
comes to revenues
how does a company like blend scale
so how do you how do you scale a company
like this and how do you strategically
think as the ceo
where where you're headed as a company
that is helping other companies
um
first
as i mentioned at the beginning it's all
about building the relationship with our
clients with our current clients
listening to and understanding what is
their needs what is their passion where
they want to grow their business and
make sure that we can support them
wherever they go
and we see the demand for
more videos uh with more uh
localized solution localized sites that
they need to have we see how they're
struggling with seo with content
lighting and this is how we actually
recruiting the community that we have we
also
see and literally the most important
thing for us we also see how the
ongoing needs
for their business and when you have an
ongoing needs you can develop more ai
tools
so you can learn their needs and you
only do the improvement so you can save
lots of costs
and you can optimize the slas for them
so anytime that they're actually
launching a new product anytime that the
company uh
that keep coming with the new service
that they want to launch we know
90 of their language already in our
system so we can really run it very fast
for them and deliver it in any language
that they need so
this early on as far as the stickiness
with our clients and how they we can
keep them with us we are listening uh
developing the solutions based based on
their needs and making sure that uh we
can support them with the scale so
this really where we actually focusing
the most which
force us quite often to develop things
that we don't have yet because we see
the trend we see the next client we see
their demands we see their challenges
and we know that if we are not going to
do it someone else will do it for them
tell me a little bit about your own you
know your your own self and take me back
even you know elementary school middle
school what really sparked your
curiosity what really fascinated you
as you as you were growing up
um
i think i can say that i'm a people
person and being a people person that he
can take me back even to the scouts
being at the scouts
living in jerusalem having lots of
friends
being you know
being a madrid being a guide of the
the the youth movement
and taking some responsibilities and
that is starting to grow over there into
the armies and so on so it's always
about people around you that you know
that
in order to do something right you need
to do it together with it um i think
it's about building the community around
you the friendship around you which
takes you into the business i think that
today i would say it's
i see lots of similar similarities to
the being at the the scouts being with
with the friends of the army that you
know that when you go to
an industry that it's a global industry
now we are based in tel aviv
uh i think that
the vast majority of our clients are not
here right we need to really manage a
global business overseas now we have a
training in with a team in china team in
hong kong uh in the uk in los angeles
london sorry i mentioned that in other
places in romania and ukraine
we know that in order to manage this
business you need to have the right
people around you you need to have the
environment of people they want to fight
together they want to win together they
want to think together and it needs to
be a team and i think this is definitely
something that i'm going back to my
childhood going back to my youth going
back to working with people around me
that you trust that you believe that you
love and you know that with them you can
win so
that's definitely something i'm taking
back from there to today
i love it and where do you draw your
inspiration from today
in day to day personally professionally
i'm tourist to learn i have to say that
uh
speaking with customers
learning about new businesses that
i know nothing about them now you can
imagine that we support so many
verticals
that are far away from what we do
mining and and
and and pharma and even during orbits a
lot of medicines that you know i never
heard about them but we know that we
support them and you speak with the
customers and you listen to what they do
what they what's
what's exciting what excites them and
you know that
what they do is amazing and if i can
make them global they will grow their
business and in many cases they will do
good to the world
i love it and i also love the fact that
we have the
privilege of connecting clients
from western country from developing
countries to
countries that the emerging countries
that they are over there with endless
talented people
but those talented people
they always seek for opportunities and
if you can combine between those between
the two of them if you can really bring
those customers that they have the the
passion they have the visions to grow
their business globally to the same
talented people that they speak the
right languages they have they have
knowledge in different uh verticals and
if you know how to put them together and
it's a win-win in fact it's a
win-win-win because we are also enjoying
the fact that we matching the right
people to the right clients
but i think uh this dives us all uh
and this is a very motivated uh i would
say impact to the entire team when we
see those successes when we see when you
go on a zoo meeting speaking with a
client that they need 17 different
languages and you see 17 people on the
zoom speaking 17 different languages
it's amazing
and if you have to choose a few words
to
think about yourself
what you know whether it's through your
work with bland or with the with you
know exactly what you mentioned now
or more on a personal side what are some
words that come to mind that represent
you
i'm curious
sometimes too much
yeah
it's hard for me to go in the elevator
or not to ask someone a little bit about
them and so my kids are always like
they're trying to
shush me and then don't ask don't start
the conversation but the same with
clients i i i want to know uh i think it
makes me smarter so i this is how i
build my relationship with the client so
i am curious
i think that i am creative
uh trying to find the solutions for
for challenges
makes me happy
and
thinking a little bit out of the box or
even a lot out of the box
definitely
[Music]
inspires me
and
people person uh i like it working with
people communicating with people
building a solution with people and and
i think definitely
uh
this is part of who i am
i love it
wonderful thank you so much for being
here this was amazing and yeah i really
enjoyed our time together and i and i
learned a lot and i think that what
you're doing obviously is so impactful
and important today and critical for
every business and and i can only
imagine what it's like to go through an
actual use case with a company
and it's almost like building a puzzle
together which at the end opens up a
whole new world and a whole new
demographic for that business so thank
you for sharing your time with me and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
very much thank you it was a pleasure
thank you take care